we're going to look at one of America's
most resilient industries payday loans
one in 20 households have taken one out
at some point it's a nine billion dollar
industry and payday loan outlets are all
over the place there are more payday
loan stores in America than Starbucks
and McDonald's both and Starbucks or
McDonald's McDonald's I didn't know
there was more of anything in the u.s.
than McDonald's
including people and grains of sand and
the payday loan industry has only been
around for just over 20 years even Ebola
looks at that growth rate and thinks
that's impressive you guys spread fast
and it's not just the number of
companies it's the variety
you've got fast cash cash central speedy
cash a quick cash with the word quick
spelled wrong and quick cash with both
quick and cash run because what could be
more reassuring than a business that
can't correctly spell either their
product or the speed at which they're
getting it to you there are so many
different options that there are even
services to help match you to a lender
and you cannot have avoided these ads hi
might are here I might owe loyalty hi
I'm Martha works for money mutual Colin
goddamn money mutual can get up to a
thousand dollars in your checking
account by tomorrow the card bill bill
pay the medical emergency handled extra
cash it's all payday done thanks Montel
quick question though how the hell are
you a financial spokesman everyone isn't
that the guy who did that episode on how
it's hard to be the less pretty
conjoined twin everybody be quiet this
guy might have some pretty sound
financial advice when something is this
popular and this prevalent you owe it to
yourself to find out exactly what it is
much in the way that I finally gave in
and read all for Twilight books
I'm on Team Bella by the way team Bella
she doesn't need a man to define her
that's not the point the point is what
is a payday loan what is a payday loan a
payday loan is a quick way to get the
cash you need to cover an unexpected
expense like a car repair or doctor bill
it's called a payday loan because the
loan balance is typically due on your
next payday oh that does make sense I
thought it was a loan that you repaid in
payday candy bars your ways better your
your way is better than mine clearly
this lady is psychotically friendly and
also seems to have an appealing product
so how much might a company charge for
this sort of service often it's 300 or
400 percentage points on an annual basis
average annual rates of five hundred and
seventy percent some of those rates
legally are as high as nineteen hundred
percent a year nineteen hundred percent
even the most demanding abusive football
coaches only ask for a hundred and ten
put him in the mouth Billy give me the
mouth now now to be fair payday loan
companies will say these are short-term
loans so an annual percentage rate
doesn't apply which is true if you pay
them off immediately but many customers
don't one study showed that
three-quarters of the industry's volume
was generated by borrowers who have to
rebar o before their next pay period
basically payday loans are the Lay's
potato chips of Finance you can't have
just one and they're terrible for you
and is when you start missing payments
that you're susceptible not just too
frightening levels of interest but also
too fees that you may not have been
aware of and I was like I'd say maybe
six thousand dollars like deep you know
every payday I was here every time I got
paid I would paid off and I would get
another one and then what cycle my daddy
and I would advise anybody not to I
borrowed two hundred and fifty I thought
I would pay three hundred twenty-five I
actually paid $700 but it would have
been eleven hundred dollars had I not
gone to the bank and put a stop to this
$1,100 it is not often that a
metaphorical slippery slope cost as much
as an actual ski vacation payday loan
companies present themselves as a way
for you to get back onto your feet they
don't want you to get trapped in debt in
fact they'll help you if you fall behind
remember the friendly iced cash lady
from before what happens if you can't
pay back your loan sometimes people have
a hard time paying us back and we'll be
there to work with you if that should
happen yeah no you'll be there for
them
your business model depends on it
because an actual ice cash training
manual for employees featured a diagram
which starts with the customer applying
for an A Sloane moves through them
spending the money on that loan being
unable to pay it back and then be forced
to apply for an ace loan again you'll
notice that has a certain roundness to
it
it's basically a recycling symbol for
human misery it's the circle of dirt and
it screws us
now obviously we must not generalize
about this shitty industry some
companies hold themselves to a higher
standard
in fact the Community Financial Services
Association of America insists that
their members are different from these
shady elements of the industry they even
brag about it
in one of the most boring videos on the
Internet in our industry I mean let's be
honest there are there some there are
some companies out there that don't even
follow the law let alone follow a
standard of best practices like our
member companies do those other
companies are awful our member companies
are pillars of the community did you
know that one of them gave a kidney to a
little girl in a hospital she was in
there for tonsillitis but now she has
three kidneys we're good companies so
let's take a look at their wonderful
members and their best practices
first there's Advance America one of the
biggest companies in the industry whose
co-founder defends his business like
this the consumer demand for the product
is overwhelming and speaks for itself
okay that's fair although it's also
worth pointing out that the customer
demand for heroin is also overwhelming
and that doesn't mean it's a product
you'd necessarily recommend to your
friends to get them out of a jam Advance
America is a company whose best practice
is somehow include agreeing to an
eighteen point seven five million dollar
settlement in North Carolina after they
were accused of illegally high interest
rates but but they're just one of the
two largest companies in the business
the other company is Cash America ok so
how did they practice their best
practices Cash America was ordered to
pay 19 million dollars in refunds in
fines late last year for illegally
overcharging service members and for
destroying documents so what you like
about that illegally overcharging
service members is a ballsy business
practice they must have been the ones
driving around with those bumper
stickers that say extort our troops
but settlements like those are actually
something of a rarity and that brings us
to why the payday loan industry is
seemingly unstoppable they are
incredibly good at avoiding regulation
just look at one example in Texas they
actually tried to rein in the payday
loan industry there a few years ago but
they faced opposition from one
particular state legislature members I
just cannot see why this why this this
legislation could possibly be necessary
unless it is the big the big
institutions we've the little guys and
the little guys in his analogy are
payday loan companies although I've got
to say if you spell little guys with a
dollar sign instead of an S you've got
yourself a pretty good name for a store
right there
that man is Texas State Representative
Gary Elkins and his proud defense of the
little guy is about to get a little
muddier but isn't it true that you have
12 very successful payday and title loan
locations across this state let me
answer that question for him it is true
it is true he does and they include an
outpost of the wonderfully named power
financed Texas kind of interest y'all in
some power finance but I apologize I
interrupted you stand to add to your
personal wealth considerably by killing
these bills you know what that that is
not about the bill do I know it why
madam I am the physical embodiment of
that term at this very moment you might
be thinking that that woman Vicki Truitt
is awesome you're fearlessly calling out
how the payday loan industry influences
politicians which is why it's going to
be so hard to tell you that just 17 days
after leaving office she signed on as a
lobbyist for ACE Cash Express you know
the circle people
thankfully thankfully Texas also has a
Finance Commission which oversees the
payday loan industry guess who runs that
William J white as vice president of
Cash America and was also appointed by
the governor as chairman of the state's
Finance Commission which oversees payday
loan outfits that's right the chairman
of the Commission that oversees the
payday loan industry is also at the same
time a vice president of one of the
biggest payday loan companies in the
country I call dingo I call dingo on
[Applause]
so let's just let's just quickly break
all of that down if you were hoping to
protect Texans from the payday loan
industry you would need to approach a
commission overseen by the
vice-president of a payday loan company
and then introduce a bill into the state
legislature where the owner of 12 payday
loan stores will debate the merits of
the payday loan industry with one of the
payday loan industry's future king
lobbyists apparently even cluster a
bigger in Texas but the truly chilling
skill payday loan companies have is not
how they prevent legislation from
getting passed
it's how they react when it gets through
for instance when Illinois passed an act
which applied to loans of up to 120 days
companies simply began offering loans
with terms of 121 days instead which is
like betting a dollar on the price of
right on the price is right you're
technically allowed to do it but you
know you get when Arizona outlawed
payday loans many companies shifted to
selling title loans instead which are
basically the same except they also get
to take your car for regulators it's
like it's like playing legislative
whack-a-mole just when you think you've
squashed them down somewhere up they pop
up somewhere else wearing a completely
different outfit and the most amazing
example of all of this took place in
Ohio in 2008 they somehow capped payday
loan rates at 28% any company licensed
as a short-term lender had to abide by
that but where one mole force another
mole shall rise and as of last year
there were no businesses in Ohio
licensed the short-term lenders there
was however a sudden increase of
companies registering as mortgage
lenders offering people short-term
mortgages of around $300 what now as the
lawyer for a company called cash land
explains this to a judge so cash land
would not be subject then to the
short-term loan
because it's not registered as a
short-term lender exactly you're under
the short-term loan Act by the
legislative enactment says it applies
only to those who register under the
short-term loan Act why even bother
calling yourselves mortgage lenders why
not just call yourselves peanut butter
octopus companies you can't regulate
peanut butter octopi they don't
technically exist and in the rare case
where states succeed in imposing
stringent regulations some payday loan
companies have one final trick up their
sleeve
now some payday lenders have found a
loophole by partnering with Indian
tribes that gives payday lenders the
cover of sovereign immunity to avoid
state regulations that's right
some payday lenders are currently
dressing themselves up as Native
Americans I thought only Johnny Depp was
allowed to do that how does that even
work
this payday lender kashfari has teamed
up with the Fort Belknap Indian tribe in
Montana and as you can see they're
charging online interest rates in the
700 percent range yet you can become
affiliated with a tribe and be able to
avert local and state laws in my opinion
apparently loan sharking is still legal
in this country it's true although let's
be fair no loan shark would ever go by
the name cash ferry
hey you better get me that money by
midnight are you gonna get a visit from
the kashfari
- very yes here's the problem
payday loan companies are almost
impossible to effectively regulate and
they are not going anywhere a Pew survey
found that a majority of borrowers said
payday loans take advantage of them but
a majority also said they provide relief
and that is why they are so dangerous
people sometimes need them but you have
to be absolutely sure there are no
better options
apparently 41% of those surveyed who
taken out payday loans ended up having
to borrow from family or porn
possessions or other things that they
could have done in the first place just
to pay off that payday loan and yet
payday loans superficially do look
easier all these commercials they're
enticing and they're also everywhere the
least we can do is launch a counter
campaign with a celebrity spokesperson
of our own to remind people to make sure
they explore all their better options
first hi I'm Sarah Silverman if you're
considering taking out a payday loan I'd
like to tell you about a great
alternative it's called anything else
the way it works is instead of taking
out a payday loan you literally do
anything else sell your sperm sell some
blood throw yourself in front of a rich
guys car he'll throw money at the
problem just to make that go away
are you an old person and need money
take things your all no one's gonna stop
you you're not gonna go to jail go to
the grocery store right now fill up a
cart with everything you need and walk
the data there you know what people will
pay you to pee on them that's true
duties to duties are more like double I
know this for a fact I it doesn't matter
but it's something that you have to do
every day anyway right by not doing it
you are literally flushing money down
the toilet it's irresponsible there's
money inside of you it's like Dorothy
having the power to go home the hold
night the point is no decision in your
life will be worse than dealing with
these payday loan mothers their mother
there's their fears of mothers so if
you're thinking about getting a payday
loan just simply pick up the phone then
put it down again and do literally
anything else do it now
[Applause]